[Musique]
il fut un temps où ses idoles plus
grandes que nature créée pour divertir
les jeunes était méprisé du monde adulte
dans ce nouveau millénaire par contre
ces personnages nés il y a plus d'un
demi-siècle ont émergé à nouveau pour
dominer le monde du cinéma à l'échelle
planétaire
voici l'histoire de la transition des
super-héros de la page dessinée au grand
écran et de leur conquête de la culture
populaire
ce que les bandes dessinées avaient de
plus que les films c'est qu'elles
étaient en avance sur leur public
c'était plus coûteux et facile à
produire 60 ans plus tard Hollywood
rattrape enfin son retard
les personnages dans lesquels on peut se
reconnaître mais qui sont capables de
choses impossibles qu'on aimerait tous
pouvoir faire exerce toujours un attrait
sur le public il vole il se balance d'un
édifice à l'autre avec des toiles
d'araignées il tabasse des brutes il y a
donc quelque chose de fondamentalement
cool et attrayant chez les super-héros
tellement que c'est devenu le courant
dominant
[Musique]
nous sommes allésées 1989 un nouveau
phénomène médiatique vient s'emparer de
l'imagination du public partout dans le
monde
l'anticipation est à son comble depuis
qu'on a annoncé la production de longs
métrages de Batman mise en scène par le
jeune réalisateur Tim Burton
à l'approche de la sortie du film il
devient impossible d'ignorer cet
engouement qui s'empare des villes du
monde entier
[Musique]
c'est le début de ce qu'on appellera
bientôt la batmania
c'était tellement étrange l'anticipation
était palpable j'étais encore tout jeune
quand la bande-annonce est sortie mes
amis et moi on a payé une place au
cinéma juste pour l'avoir parce que
l'Internet n'existait pas encore
[Musique]
réalité alternative me suis réveillé
pour voir la bande-annonce d'un film de
Batman
bien que cette frénésie est comme objet
un nouveau long-métrage la sortie de ce
film ravive l’intérêt pour le personnage
de Batman lui-même et contribue à
revitaliser le média qui lui a donné
naissance les bandes dessinées de
super-héros
à l'époque où le Batman de Tim Burton
est sorti il y avait beaucoup de monde
qui lisait ses bandes dessinées bien sûr
mais ce n'était pas vraiment quelque
chose de cool la publicité du film était
axée sur le symbole de la chauve-souris
au début et ça c'était cool peu importe
les acteurs tout ce qui comptait c'était
le symbole et le personnage la sortie du
film est planifiée pour coïncider avec
le 50e anniversaire de ce personnage
emblématique au cours du demi-siècle
d'existence de Batman les bandes
dessinées bon marché et les super héros
représentés dans leur page ont connu des
hauts et des bas dans la faveur du
public une chose est sûre cependant ils
n'ont jamais été jugés cool depuis les
débuts de l'industrie américaine des
bandes dessinées à la fin des années 30
on les a toujours considérés comme
divertissement puéril et éphémère
c'était une industrie qui s'adressait
aux jeunes ces BD ne coûtaient pas chers
à peine et se vendait dans les
pharmacies et les magasins de bonbons
les enfants se présentaient au comptoir
avec 20 ou 37 pour acheter quelques
fascicules qu'ils enroulaient et
mettaient dans leur poche arrière il les
échangerait peut-être plus tard avec des
amis on achetait ça avec une boisson
gazeuse et un paquet de gomme à mâcher
on les rangés sous son lit et une fois
passé les saisons on ne les relise plus
jamais
des pages de ces livres pour enfants
émergent toutefois des héros qui
captivent l'imagination des jeunes
pendant des décennies l'industrie se
concentre au départ sur les personnages
comiques et les bandes dessinées courtes
publiées dans les journaux mais deux de
ses principales icônes apparaissent dès
la fin des années 30 la maison d'édition
new-yorkaise DC Comics présentent
d'abord Superman
issus de l'imagination de Jerry Seagal
et Joe Chester dans le premier numéro
d'action comics en 1938 l'année suivante
Bob Kane et Bill Finger crée Batman le
fils tout-puissant de Krypton et le
chevalier noir de Gotham deviennent vite
les archétypes dès qu'elle s'inspireront
tous les super-héros qui suivent dans
leur sillage ils ont fait de Superman un
héros d'une autre planète c'est presque
un Dieu en réalité sans vraiment l'être
son plus grand souhait est d'être un
homme d'être Clark Kent il se trouve à
une extrémité de l'échelle les autres
super-héros lui sont tous inférieurs
Batman n'est pas du tout un super héros
il porte seulement un costume Batman est
un homme ordinaire qui s'est entraîné
pour devenir un grand détective et un
grand athlète tous les autres super
héros de bande dessinée se situent entre
ces deux personnages ce sont l'alpha et
l'oméga de notre industrie
ce succès immédiat de Superman et de
Batman auprès des jeunes lecteurs
encouragent les éditeurs de bandes
dessinées à créer de nouveaux
super-héros pour tirer parti de cet
engouement au même moment une autre
industrie commence à chercher des moyens
d'attirer le public jeunesse
depuis l'avènement du son au cinéma
Hollywood connaît un véritable âge d'or
les sociétés cinématographiques
cherchent de nouvelles sources
d'inspiration pour leur production grâce
à leur personnage quasi mythologique et
à leur style visuel dynamique les bandes
dessinées constituent une forme d'art
hautement compatible avec le cinéma
la bande dessinée à son meilleur est un
art très cinématographique les scénars
images qu'on prépare pour les films sont
comme des pages de BD plus une bande
dessinée se rapproche d'un film dans son
apparence et son déroulement plus elle
est réussie ce qui ne veut pas dire
qu'une de ces formes est supérieure à
l'autre
à la fin des années 30 et au début des
années 40 quand les gens allaient au
cinéma ça durait toute la journée il y
avait un film de série a un film de
série B des dessins animés des
courts-métrages des actualités et tout
au bas de la fiche on retrouve les films
à épisode
[Musique]
c'était le bas de l'échelle du cinéma
des films destinés aux matinées du
samedi pour enfants il pouvait durer
jusqu'à 18 minutes et était filmé en
noir et blanc avec un budget dérisoire
ça a commencé par des westerns Flash
Gordon s'est faufiler dans le Lot à la
fin des années 30 parce que quelqu'un a
décidé d'investir un dollar 50 de plus
quand les super-héros ont commencé à
paraître en 1938 40 il semblait fait
pour les films à épisode
[Musique]
une fois que les super-héros de bande
dessinée sont devenus très populaires il
était assez logique qu'on les transpose
ou tentent de les transposer au grand
écran Série 5 a beaucoup influencé Bob
Kennedy
Robinson un des premiers dessinateurs de
Batman intégré beaucoup d'images
inspirées des films expressionnistes
allemands dans ces dessins
enfants je regardais les petits films de
Batman qui étaient très mauvais et ceux
de Superman qui était excellents quand
j'allais au cinéma avec mes amis
il ne s'agissait donc pas seulement des
BD qu'on avait enroulé dans notre poche
arrière mais aussi de ses feuilles temps
qu'on voyait le samedi matin avec les
dessins animés toutes ces choses
faisaient partie d'un processus évolutif
qui a été interrompu en 1953
alors même que Superman vient tout juste
de réussir son passage à la télévision
avec une série fort populaire qui en
fait un personnage connu de tous les
bandes dessinées tombent sous le regard
scrutateur de la censure l'obsession
collective de la nation américaine au
sujet de la délinquance juvénile a
atteint son paroxysme on estime
désormais que les bandes dessinées ont
une mauvaise influence sur les jeunes à
l'esprit facilement influençable après
un bref moment de gloire les super héros
retournent bien vite dans l'obscurité où
il reste jusqu'au bouleversement sociaux
qu'apporte les années 60 la percée des
Beatles annonce en effet l'aube d'une
culture populaire dynamique axée sur la
jeunesse c'est dans ce nouveau monde
intrépide que le détective masqué de
Gotham revient sur les écrans
contrairement à son incarnation passée
des courts-métrages à petit budget ce
Batman 6 fait sensation partout dans le
monde
[Musique]
est apparu à la télévision américaine en
1966 il n'y avait pas grand monde qu'il
avait déjà vu en dehors de ces quelques
séries en court-métrage cette fois-ci il
s'agissait d'une série télévisée en
couleur de plusieurs millions de dollars
diffusés deux fois par semaine est-ce
que les gens oublient mais qui est très
important c'est qu'elle pensait à 19h30
c'était donc la première fois qu'on ne
ciblait pas uniquement les enfants avec
les aventures d'un super-héros la série
Batman est devenue un phénomène pour
adulte il y a eu une explosion de
produits dérivés de Batman
j'osais même dire que la Batmobile de la
série de 1966 67 et probablement encore
la voiture la plus reconnaissable de
l'histoire américaine
[Musique]
l'émission de télévision Batman des
années 1960 a eu énormément de succès
mais c'était très kitsch
les enfants étaient enchantés de voir
leur héros à la télévision et il prenait
généralement ses aventures au sérieux
les adultes par contre regardez sa pour
rire par conséquent il se moquait aussi
des super-héros de bande dessinée en
général
c'était censé être caricatural c'était
censé être satirique les textes étaient
à la fois stupides et géniaux c'était
tout simplement fantastique ce n'était
pas le vrai Batman mais c'était une
bonne parodie c'était inspirant parce
qu'on pouvait regarder l'émission et se
dire ce n'est pas le Batman que je
connais mais au moins ils adaptent des
BD c'est un début qui a compris à
l'époque que ça marquait effectivement
le début de quelque chose personne mais
maintenant on peut regarder en arrière
et dire oui c'était bel et bien le
commencement
alors que cette parodie de style pop art
catapulte Batman au cœur même de la
Révolution culturelle des années 60 dans
le monde de la bande dessinée une
nouvelle force est en train de
transformer l'industrie et d'en réécrire
les règles il s'agit bien sûr de moi
bien que l'entreprise et ses origines
dans le boom d'avant-garde de la bande
dessinée ce n'est que 30 ans plus tard
qu'elle fait véritablement sentir sa
présence dans le milieu sous l'impulsion
remarquable de son éditeur Stanley
dans un remarquable élan d'inspiration
il crée une foule de super héros très
moderne dont la tresse avait rat des
plus durables
les Avengers Iron Man voilà le cadre de
grands personnages que Stanley a créé
pour Marvel avec Jack Ruby et Steve
deadco il les a tous créés en moins de
deux ans ce qui est ahurissant en plus
il a pris ses notes costumés ces
marginaux et il les a fait vivre à New
York ça lui permettait d'aborder les
tensions des années 1960 l'alien nation
et la peur des radiations et du
communisme développant ainsi la
psychologie de ces personnages et les
rendants humains
Stanley a cherché à donner à tous les
héros de Marvel si ridicule soit-il une
base dans une réalité à laquelle le
public pouvait s'identifier
je ne m’intéressais ni à la vie de Clark
Kent ni à celle de Superman Bruce Wayne
était franchement aussi loin de la
réalité que je voyais autour de moi que
Donald Trump peut l'être aujourd'hui
c'est ce qu'il y avait de plus court
chez Spider-Man chez Peter Parker
c'était un étudiant du secondaire qui
ressemblait au geeks c'est ce qui leur
plaisait en lui il portait une cravate
et un gilet comme eux ça les touchait
directement
les noms des personnages de Marvel
deviennent bientôt familiers effectuant
rapidement le passage de l'imprimé à la
télévision grâce à des séries de dessin
animé à succès
cela dit ces séries attirent encore en
grande partie que des jeunes et les
super-héros restent aux yeux de la
majorité un simple divertissement pour
enfant
cette situation va toutefois changer au
cours de la décennie suivante avec
l'acquisition de DC Comics par Warner
communication un vaste empire médiatique
doté d'une puissante division
cinématographique
cela mène à la première superproduction
de l'histoire des super-héros en 1978
avec nul autre que le légendaire homme
d'acier
[Musique]
d'ici sur le marché des bandes dessinées
mais c'était tout le contraire au cinéma
car d'ici avait les personnages les plus
connus du grand public quand le film
Superman avec Christopher rivé sorti il
a donc obtenu un énorme succès
[Musique]
c'est arrivé à un moment particulier où
les films événements étaient
soudainement devenus très attirant pour
l'auditoire l'idée de faire la queue
autour du patine maison pour voir un
film semblait désormais très excitant
surtout parce que c'était un personnage
très connu probablement le plus célèbre
d'entre tous et bien sûr il y a le fait
qu'il s'agit d'un film familial sans
être film pour enfant les deux premiers
films de Superman avec Christopher
Reeves réalisé par Richard Darner et
riches Leicester sont des comptes
mythologiques américains avec le
dévoilement de ses origines
Superman 2 est une fable grecque
fantastique il doit décider si
l'abandonne ses pouvoirs pour être
heureux ou s'il sauve le monde mais en
vivant dans le malheur c'est comme la
mythologie
avec une distribution composée de
grandes vedettes et le plus toujours au
budget jamais consacré à long métrage
Superman tournait simultanément avec
Superman 2 connaît un énorme succès
commercial et critique par ailleurs
malgré les limites des effets visuels de
l'époque la publicité n'est pas
trompeuse le film fait effectivement
croire au public qu'un homme peut voler
le défi pour tout adaptation de bandes
dessinées et de la rendre réaliste tout
film de science-fiction tout film de
genre qui fait appel aux fantastique ou
à des éléments du genre exigent la
suspension volontaire de l'incrédulité
il faut cependant être en mesure de
croire que Christopher Reeves vole dans
le premier souplement que ces
personnages là ont les pouvoirs qui leur
sont attribués pour ça il faut surtout
que les acteurs croient vraiment qu'ils
lancent des rayons optiques de leurs
yeux qui lisent les pensées des autres
ou qu'ils se téléporte sur de grandes
distances sinon le public ne suivra pas
la sortie du film Superman ne déclenche
toutefois pas de nouvelles tendances peu
d'adaptation d'histoire de super-héros
seront produites dans les années qui
suivent dans le monde de la bande
dessinée par contre les choses changent
Batman est le personnage pour qui c'est
le plus évident il subit une révision
radicale qui l'amène bien loin de la
caricature télévisée des années 60 les
ventes de Batman ont vraiment augmenté
grâce à l'émission malheureusement les
BD ont commencé à imiter le style de
celle-ci quand le nombre de
téléspectateurs a chuté et que
l'émission a été annulée les éditeurs ne
savaient plus trop quoi faire
heureusement le scénariste Denis Omir et
le dessinateur NIR à Adams ont adopté
une approche très différente ils ont
complètement réorienté Batman le plus
loin possible de l'émission de télé ils
sont retournés au Batman des origines de
1939-1940 qui s'était fait aseptiser par
la suite c'était un redresseur de tort
ténébreux qui ne sortait que la nuit et
qui représentait la vengeance le
châtiment il avait eu une vie très
difficile Franck Miller s'est ensuite
inspiré des aventures en solo de Batman
pour créer la saga de Dark Knight au
début des années 1980
c'est cette vision lugubre de Batman qui
transporte les super-héros dans un monde
plus réaliste au cours des années 80
avec la sortie de la bande dessinée
phares de Frank Miller de Dark knighters
les limites de la forme à l'instar des
bandes dessinées européennes il devient
plus adulte plus sombre et souvent plus
violent en février 1989 les
bandes-annonces pour le long-métrage de
Tim Burton commence à circuler au même
moment au DC Comics publient une
histoire en quatre numéros qui se
terminent par le meurtre de Rawdon
[Musique]
Batman est devenu une sorte de
personnage de référence à ce moment-là
toutes les BD devaient être aussi
sérieuses et aussi sombres que Batman
qui montrait la voix évidemment quand
Tim Burton a décidé de s'attaquer aux
personnages et que le scénariste a été
choisi ils ont regardé ce qui se faisait
alors dans la BD de sorte que leur
version du personnage était aussi très
sombre
et comme il s'agissait de Tim Burton il
a apporté sa touche à l'ensemble ce qui
a donné le film qu'on connaît si
l'enthousiasme pour Batman est
alimenté tout au long de l'été 89 le
film lui-même est présenté comme la
création du réalisateur Tim Burton ce
qui est la clé de son attrait
cinéaste doué et possédant une vision
distinctive il marque l'arrivée d'une
nouvelle génération à Hollywood jeune
moderne et moins conventionnel
[Musique]
le Batman de Tim Burton était très
personnel
l'aspect visuel et fantastique
Burton a une excellente vision des
choses on a invité un grand talent
créatif dans le domaine de la bande
dessinée il n'aurait pas pu faire le
film autrement même s'il avait essayé
[Musique]
a réussi à insérer son film de Batman
dans son univers bien à lui quand on
regarde la longue liste de ces films de
a nightmare Christmas à Beetlejuice en
passant par Edward sesurances on
constate une certaine homogénéité ils
sont tous issus du même ADN Burton a su
conserver les éléments qui font que
Batman et Batman aux yeux des gens grâce
à une ville sombre il y a un élément
omniprésent de danger ce qui justifie la
présence de quelqu'un comme Batman pour
mener une guerre contre le crime Burton
a su représenter tout ce que Batman a
des essentiel tout en y laissant son
empreinte
un film suscite pourtant la controverse
les amateurs de la bande dessinée sont
d'abord indignés par l'annonce que
Michael Keaton interprétera le rôle
principal acteur jusque-là associe
uniquement la comédie kitten s'avère
finalement un choix inspiré
avec Jack Nicholson qui vole la vedette
dans le rôle du Joker Kimber Singer qui
s'impose enfin au cinéma en jouant
vikiverle et une bande musicale composée
de titres originaux de Prince Batman
ressuscite non seulement les films de
super-héros il établit de nouvelles
règles pour réussir le lancement d'une
super production
c'était la première méga production de
l'air moderne dont le succès était
prédestiné
le film a battu et de beaucoup le record
pour un premier week-end il a amassé 100
millions de dollars en 10 jours ça a
montré à Hollywood qu'il y avait tout un
monde de propriétés intellectuelles qui
ne tiraient pas nécessairement leur
origine dans le cinéma mais qu'on
pouvait y adapter
inspiré par cette réussite l'industrie
du cinéma ne se concentre toutefois pas
uniquement sur les super-héros Batman a
après tout une longue histoire autant en
tant qu’émission de télé à succès que de
séries de bandes dessinées au cours des
années qui suivent on assiste à
l'arrivée sur les écrans de Dick Tracy
du rocketer et d'autres classiques des
films à épisode des années 30 et 40 les
producteurs restent cependant conscients
du potentiel économique des super-héros
ce pourquoi il se tourne vers Marvel
dans le but de trouver quelques
personnages pour le grand écran les
trois films à s'y produit de panécher
Captain America et de Fantastic Four
sont malheureusement des navets à budget
minuscule que la plupart des spectateurs
ne verront jamais
les bandes dessinées de majorité les
plus vendus aux États-Unis à l'époque il
y avait assurément des films en tirés ou
du moins il y en aura un jour mais les
premiers qui sont sortis n'étaient pas
ceux qu'on aurait voulu voir et ce
n'était pas non plus des films dont les
créateurs étaient particulièrement fiers
si les personnages de Marvel ne
parviennent pas à faire la transition
vers le grand écran ils ont toujours
énormément de succès dans leur forme
dessinée et l'industriel même traverse
une période de grande prospérité grâce à
la maturité croissante de ce média et un
changement significatif dans la culture
des jeunes les bandes dessinées se
vendent désormais en nombre records de
nouveaux éditeurs et de nouveaux titres
apparaissent d'ailleurs constamment
à l'été 1992 alors que cette
sous-culture s'impose dans le grand
public le chevalier noir de Michael
Keaton fait son retour dans Batman
Returns ayant démontré sa valeur au
box-office avec le premier film le
réalisateur Tim Burton a maintenant
carte blanche et laisse libre cours à
son imagination proposant cette fois une
vision beaucoup plus excentrique du
personnage en opposant Batman autant à
la vilénite du Pingouin de Dany DeVito
qu'à la malice de la Catwoman de Michel
Pfeiffer Burtin divise l'opinion
publique
c'est Tim Burton qui a décidé de
raconter un conte de fées gothique se
déroulant dans le monde de Batman
ce qui m'a toujours frappé même quand je
l'ai vu pour la première fois à l'âge de
12 ans c'est que s'il n'était pas basé
sur des personnages qu'on connaît tous
ce film aurait été acclamé comme une des
grandes œuvres fantastiques
hallucinantes de notre époque
terrible
[Musique]
quand je suis allée voir Batman Returns
j'ai adoré ça l'aspect esthétique était
complètement différent de tout ce que
j'avais vu auparavant du moins dans un
monde issu de la bande dessinée un côté
gothique sombre et sérieux mais pas
funeste car ça avait quand même quelque
chose d'amusant
adolescente je n'ai jamais eu
l'impression que les super-héros ou les
bandes dessinées étaient vraiment pour
moi
à l'époque où j'ai grandi ce n'était pas
une chose à laquelle s'intéressait
beaucoup de jeunes filles je n'avais
donc pas de super héros féminin comme
idole mais grâce à ce film il y avait
maintenant cette femme incroyablement
cool qui tombe par la fenêtre et se fait
lécher par des chats pour devenir cet
antihéroïne extrêmement sexy insolente
puissante et passionnante j'ai toujours
été une grande fan de Catwoman et de la
voir pas seulement au grand écran pas
seulement comme personnage principal
mais aussi en tant que femme qui est
victime de sexisme au bureau une
question qu'on a toujours pas vraiment
réglé le fait de l'avoir elle est grand
c'était phénoménal elle était puissante
elle était sexy ce qui en passant n'a
absolument rien de mal j'adorais ce
costume il était si serré qu'il fallait
le coudre sur le corps de cette pauvre
femme et elle se défendait sans problème
contre Batman c'était incroyable
de ces personnages et le ton sinistre du
film où ils évoluent en limite la trait
auprès du public je travaillais sur les
BD de Batman quand le film est sorti nos
vents ont baissés parce que les parents
étaient vraiment troublés par le film
il s'attendait à avoir un film de Batman
qui convenait à leurs enfants le monde
du Pingouin a été très effrayant et la
femme chat a été élu si tellement
perturbante que les parents en sortaient
troubler
en dépit de son excellent week-end
ouverture le film fait l'objet d'une
réaction négative du public ce qui
pousse le géant de la restauration
rapidement a annulé un lucratif accord
commercial n'ayant manifestement jamais
été conçu comme un film familial Batman
Returns s'avère cependant trop
controversé pour une super production
d'été cela ne décourage toutefois pas
les petites sociétés de production
d'investir dans l'adaptation de bandes
dessinées l'essor qui connaît cette
industrie depuis quelques années fait
d'ailleurs en sorte qu'il y a maintenant
beaucoup plus de personnages parmi
lesquels choisir des éditeurs
indépendants comme Carly bird Dark Horse
ont créé une multitude de nouveaux héros
et des films comme de masques
parfois notable avec ses créations plus
récentes
los Angel 1995 il a fallu 3 ans ou tête
pensante de Warner Brothers pour
réfléchir et redéfinir Batman
encore sous le choc de l'indignation
provoquée par le singulier film
précédent de Tim Burton les producteurs
visent carrément le marché familial
cette fois-ci une fois de plus la
distribution est impressionnante Val
Kilmer remplace Michael Ketten dans le
rôle principal Tommy Lee jonescar
interprète double face le meilleur
acteur comique de Hollywood Jim Carrey
joue le Sphinx Cresco downl contre le
personnage de Raven et Nico Kidman
complète la distribution derrière la
caméra l'ancien concepteur de costume
George Michael cherche à apporter une
vision différente à la série le film qui
en résulte Batman Forever obtient un
succès commercial mais s’avère une
impasse créative
quand Tim Burton s'est éloigné du projet
il restait au producteur à déterminer
s'il poursuivait dans la direction déjà
établie ou s'ils en empruntaient une
nouvelle par ailleurs le souvenir de
l'émission de télévision exerçait encore
une certaine influence c'était donc là
les trois grandes orientations possibles
pour la série de films
ce à quoi personne n'a pensé c'était de
s'inspirer des bandes dessinées
l'attitude de Hollywood à l'égard des BD
c'était comment peut-on arranger ça pour
en faire un film chaque fois qu'ils
adaptent une bande dessinée il se
demande d'abord de quels éléments ils
doivent se débarrasser l'interaction de
toutes ces différentes forces a
finalement donné Batman Forever c'était
tapageur c'était vulgaire les impératifs
étaient avant tout commerciaux et il y
avait beaucoup de répliques qui se
voulaient drôles
est sorti le public était toujours
disposé à aller voir un film de Batman
mais c'est là que la série a commencé à
déraper il y avait deux méchants si on
était tous prêts à accepter un nouvel
acteur principal valkymer a interprété
le rôle comme un somnambule et s'est
fait éclipser par les méchants tamily
Jones jouait double face comme si
c'était le Joker
ce personnage ne ressemble pourtant pas
au Joker et Jim Kerry jouait Jim Carrey
[Musique]
il semble que Shumaker ait voulait
imposer sa propre vision stylistique qui
était fortement inspirée de l'émission
des années 1960
les prises de vue de travail des
couleurs néons au lieu de sel
fluorescentes de la série de télé
et les battements faut-il vraiment en
dire plus
cette version de Batman est certes plus
appropriée comme divertissement familial
ce que confirme la participation de mec
download mais il s'agit d'un retour à la
parodie et à la caricature les amateurs
de la bande dessinée et les critiques de
cinéma ne manquent donc pas d'exprimer
leur déception un Schumacher revient
pour la suite en 1997 avec George
Clooney dans le rôle principal Brothers
s'attend à un autre grand succès cet
extravagance spectacle à la distribution
imposante sera pourtant considérée comme
l'un des pires films jamais produit
je ne veux pas être méchante mais j'ai
l'impression que Shumaker a détruit à
lui seul la série
pour sa défense je ne crois pas que
c'était entièrement de sa faute
les gens de Warner Brothers ne
comprenaient ni l'histoire ni les
personnages
c'est pour ça qu'ils l'ont laissé suivre
cette interprétation
mais
ce n'était pas bon
[Musique]
heur
de la série ils ont bien dû comprendre
que ces films n'étaient pas un magasin
de t-shirts où les clients reviendraient
été après été
j'ai entendu Kevin fagui de Marvel
parlait de Batman and Robin comme du
plus important film de super-héros de
l'histoire parce que c'était tellement
mauvais que n'importe quoi d'autre
aurait été mieux quelqu'un a donc eu
l'idée désespéré de prêter attention au
matériel d'origine comme il ne restait
plus rien d'autre à essayer de toute
façon autant imiter ce que faisait les
artisans de la BD
il faudra cependant des années avant que
cette nouvelle approche ne se concrétise
entre temps c'est la débâcle dans
l'industrie en effet les ventes de
bandes dessinées de super-héros
s'effondre soudainement après une longue
période de boum à la fin de 1996 le chef
de fil du secteur Marvel se place sous
la protection de la loi sur les
faillites les bandes dessinées
n'arrivant plus à maintenir l'entreprise
à flot son seul espoir réside dans les
films qui sont alors en développement
dans diverses sociétés de production
cinématographiques compte tenu de la
piètre performance de ces films jusque
là au box-office les chances que Marvel
sentir semble bien mince 1998 voit
pourtant la sortie d'un succès
providentiel un film centré sur un
personnage dans peu de gens connaissent
même l'existence Blade
a été la première incursion réussie de
Marvel dans le monde cinématographique
mais 99% des gens qui sont allés voir ce
film ont pensé c'est un film d'action et
d'horreur avec Wesley Snipes où il joue
un vampire qui en tue d'autres super
c'était étonnant que Blade était le
premier succès cinématographique de
Marvel même pour les lecteurs DBD Blade
était un personnage peu connu il était
dans la série de Marvel tout move drop
dans les années 1970
Blade est un personnage à moitié vampire
qui chasse les vampires il est très
important pour pouvoir décrire un
personnage en deux ou trois phrases au
plus ça le rend plus facile à accepter
pour le public le succès de Blade est dû
au fait que l'acteur principal était une
vedette bien établie de films d'action
Wesley Snipes et qu'il s'agissait d'un
film très divertissant sur les vampires
ça a probablement été un des premiers
films attirés parti de ce qui allait
devenir la mode des vampires sans
l'aspect romantique de la série Twilight
il y a une leçon intéressante à tirer de
Blade le personnage est en si peu connu
personne ne pouvait dire il me semble
qu'il devrait plutôt être comme ça quand
on met Super-Man ou Batman à l'écran
c'est presque comme un test de Rechard
n'importe quel producteur de film aura
déjà une idée de ce qu'un film de
Superman doit contenir ce n'est pas
nécessairement une bonne chose si on lui
demande à quoi devrait ressembler un
film de Blade par contre il n'aura pas
de réponse ce qui peut être positif
pendant son heure la plus sombre il
s'agit non seulement d'un succès en soi
mais aussi d'un encouragement pour les
producteurs des grands studios qui ont
de nombreux projets similaires en
développement cette résurrection
providentielle n'aurait pas pu survenir
à un meilleur moment la technologie
numérique a progressé à une vitesse
effarante au cours des années 90 et
cette évolution a directement alimenté
le monde cinématographique pour Jurassic
Park terminer YouTube
les effets spéciaux numériques et les
images de synthèse permettant fait au
cinéaste de représenter l'impossible de
façon réaliste
à l'aube du nouveau millénaire un film
pionnier inspiré du style des bandes
dessinées et lancé laissant entrevoir ce
que sera l'avenir du cinéma
quel a été le premier grand film de
bande dessinée celui qui nous a montré
ce qu'on pouvait faire avec ce média
selon moi c'est de mai ce n'est pas une
adaptation de BD mais je m'en fiche mais
what's House qui se sont inspirés des
univers de Jack Kirby et de tous les
autres grands de la bande dessinée ils
en parlaient le langage ils ont
comprenaient les lois il savait ce que
ça a d'émerveillant ce sont eux qui les
premiers ont réussi à transposer ça à
l'écran
la dernière scène du premier film quand
Neo s'envole vers le ciel
tous ceux dans le cinéma qui possédaient
une boîte pleine de BD à la maison on
pensait la même chose
c'est Superman c'est de ça que ça
devrait avoir l'air pourquoi ne jamais
vu ça dans un film de super-héros leur
attente est maintenant terminée en l'an
2000 après des années de films de
qualité inférieure qui n'ont jamais
réussi à donner vie à l'univers Marvel
l'un des titres phares de la maison
d'édition effectue sa transition vers le
grand écran de X-Men créé par Stan Lee
et Jack Kirby cette bande dessinée est
celle qui se vend le mieux au cours des
années 90 cela dit elle n'a pas toujours
été si populaire les X-Men ont une
longue histoire à l’ambiqué c'est une
des dernières équipes de super-héros
créés par Lee et Kirby au début des
années 1960 leur série semblait être
retirée du marché toutes les semaines
dans les années 1960 et 70 par la suite
entre les mains de Chris Clement et Dave
ils ont connu une incroyable Renaissance
pour moi la trait de la Syrie était
simple un groupe de personnages très
cool qui viennent d'être créés une
ardoise totalement vierge donc et la
chance de travailler avec l'un des
meilleurs dessinateurs de l'industrie
Dave cockerum Spider Man existait depuis
plusieurs années les fantastiques forts
aussi tous les autres personnages
avaient déjà une histoire établie dans
toutes les autres séries un groupe
d'auteurs venus avant moi avait défini
les personnages les nouveaux ex-man
représentaient un territoire vierge je
ne pouvais pas résister les X-Men sont
très différents
un film de X-Men est en développement
depuis longtemps c'est le réalisateur de
Terminator James Cameron qui est d'abord
lié au projet malheureusement bien que
Tony of centeryfox en détiennent les
droits depuis 1994 la valeur réelle de
son acquisition lui échappe
les gens de Fox n'arrivaient pas à
comprendre le concept j'ai donc fini par
le récré un mémo pour leur expliquer qui
sont les ex-man ce en quoi la Syrie est
différente
je leur ai dit que ce n'est pas une
histoire de super-héros mais bien des
gens qui essaient de se tailler une
place dans un monde qui franchement ne
veut pas d'eux ils doivent donc prouver
leur valeur et démontrer qu'ils ont le
droit d'exister
d'immigrants qui arrivent aux Etats-Unis
et qui cherche assis intégrer
[Applaudissements]
c'est un concept plus séduisant auquel
il est plus facile de s'identifier et
qui est malheureusement plus réaliste
que les aventures d'un milliardaire qui
veut combattre le crime
avec le jeune réalisateur acclamé Brian
le projet suscite d'énormes attentes
comme pour Batman plus de 10 ans
auparavant les femmes sont inquiets
quant à la distribution de leur
personnage préféré le violent anti-héros
du Scott est le premier acteur choisit
pour ce rôle mais il doit se retirer du
projet si me revient alors à son choix
initial Russell Crowe
celui-ci n'étant pas disponible il
suggère plutôt son ami et compatriote
australien few Jackman un acteur plus
connu pour des comédies musicales et
comme Michael keen avant lui il s'agit
d'un choix inspiré le succès des films
des X-Men dépendait du choix de l'acteur
qui interpreterait
c'est sans doute le personnage le plus
aimé de l'univers de Marvaux ses
origines ont été entourées de mystères
pendant très longtemps le sort du film
reposait donc sur les épaules de Hugh
Jackman allait-il jouer Wolverine d'une
manière convaincante pour les fans
ne serait pas entré dans la culture
populaire générale sans Jackman les deux
sont intrinsèquement liés l'un à l'autre
aucun de ses films n'aurait marcher sans
lui il est naturellement charismatique
beau sans être mignon viril sans être
brutal et il nous fait croire en la
sauvagerie du personnage
ils ont construit toute la série et
l'ensemble des personnages autour de lui
c'était en australien a connu venu de
nulle part pour remplacer quelqu'un
d'autre et c'est lui qui a tout fait
le metteur en scène Bryan Seigneur
rassemble une solide équipe d'acteurs
dont les vétérans britanniques Patrick
swayz et
la vedette montante Halle Berry
à l'instar de la bande dessinée le film
confère une touche réaliste et
dramatique à sa prémisse fantastique
l'ambition de X-Men se révèle
immédiatement le film commence dans un
camp de concentration nazi avec une
famille qu'on amène à sa mort ce n'est
pas net Betty qui fait des blagues à
Métropolis ce n'est pas Jack Nicholson
qui fait le guignol devant la caméra ça
dit nous plongeons dans le monde réel
nous intégrons le monde réel
[Applaudissements]
le film a réalisé des entrées de 55
millions de dollars à son week-end
d'ouverture c'était le cinquième
meilleur résultat de tous les temps
jusque là et le meilleur pour un film
qui n'était pas une suite
comme Bryan Singer de disposait pas d'un
milliard de dollars il a dû mettre
l'accent sur le drame sur les
personnages et sur le récit c'est
pourquoi ce film tient toujours pas
tellement en tant que film d'action
parce qu'il y en a eu très peu mais
comme un drame centré sur ces
personnages
c'est un film beaucoup plus mature que
c'est prédécesseurs en partie parce
qu'il aborde de grandes questions
politiques on l'a délibérément présenté
comme un film qui ne s'adresse pas
seulement aux enfants pas seulement en
fans c'est l'histoire de leurs origines
ce qui signifie qu'on n'a pas besoin
d'avoir lu la BD pour comprendre cela
dit les fervents de la série avaient la
joie et le plaisir de voir leur
personnage favoris prendre vie le dessin
est des costumes était très intéressant
avec une influence maytricks Wolverine
n'est pas affublé de son traditionnel
costume jaune tout le monde porte du
cuir tout le monde a l'air cool c'était
un film très cool
il y avait beaucoup de femmes dans ce
film la distribution a été composée à
moitié d'or et à moitié de femmes ça
attiré non seulement les gars qui
allaient voir le film de toute façon
mais aussi beaucoup de femmes parce
qu'elle voulait enfin voir des filles
qui bottent des culs
c'était tellement excitant de voir ça je
sais que pour beaucoup de gens voient
Batman au cinéma a été un grand moment
et ça l'était moi j'ai ressenti ça avec
X-Men voir toutes ces femmes se battre
j'ai adoré ça
après des premiers pas hésitants les
films de super-héros à grands budget
sont enfin sur la bonne voie grâce au
succès de X-Men les bandes dessinées
deviennent une source populaire
d'inspiration pour toutes sortes de
productions comme Ghost World de routes
sérieuses et acclamées adaptés de bandes
dessinées non fantastiques
le deuxième volet de bléde est lancé au
début de 2002 obtenant encore une fois
un succès critique et commercial c'est
toutefois la superproduction attendue
pour l'été qui attire le plus
d'attention après une série télévisée
éphémère et plusieurs dessins animés à
succès le personnage le plus connu de
Marvel se ferait maintenant un chemin
vers le grand
écrans les plus incroyables de
l'histoire de la bande dessinée Stanley
et Steve diteco ont réuni en lui toutes
les grandes caractéristiques des
super-héros
c'est un adolescent comme Robin il a
vécu une tragédie familiale comme Batman
il a une identité secrète comme Superman
ça a été un succès instantané parce que
Spider-Man était le premier héros de
bande dessinée avec du vécu qui
représentait les lecteurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le soir de la première à me dire que
c'était presque irréel après toutes ces
années passées en entendre parler je
voyais enfin un film de Spider Man
voir Spider-Man se balançait sur l'écran
pour la première fois à autant marqué le
public que le fait de voir Christopher
man
ça a été un moment très important pour
les fans des bandes dessinées
ses fans sont aussi rassurés de savoir
que pour la première fois une adaptation
cinématographique de super-héros a été
confié à l'un des leurs le réalisateur
Sam Raimi je connais Samuel depuis
longtemps c'était le réalisateur parfait
pour Spider-Man
ce qui caractérise somme c'est qu'il
adore faire des films et il adore
Spider-Man c'est un fané perdu de
Spiderman et des BD de super-héros
Spider-Man il l'adore
il s'est lancé dans ce projet avec une
attitude qu'aucun autre cinéaste
adaptant une bande dessinée n'avait eu
avant lui même si richtone a réussi avec
Superman il n'avait pas grandi plongé
dans l'univers de Superman comme Sam
Raimi a grandi avec les BD de Stanley de
Steve Jetta
Rémi savait ce qui est important dans
l'histoire de Spider-Man quand il a fait
ses choix pour le film ceci n'ont donc
pas été filtrés par Hollywood
pour interpréter ce héros Sam Raimi
rejette le choix des producteurs Freddy
princier auquel il préfère Toby meguire
un acteur qui a été acclamé par la
critique pour ses rôles dans les drames
la zone ville vstorm et Wonder boys
de l'acteur qui incarnerait Spider-Man
était donc extrêmement important tout
comme celui du réalisateur à mon avis
était le choix parfait
[Musique]
ok Sphinx
et l'apparence j'avais toujours imaginé
pile c'était parfait le premier film à
générer des recettes de plus de 100
millions de dollars en Amérique du Nord
lors de son premier weekend d'ouverture
Spiderman est une preuve de plus que
lorsqu'elles sont bien faites les
adaptations de super-héros peuvent
apporter gros l'industrie de la bande
dessinée elle profite de l'immense
auditoire mondiale que lui procure ces
méga productions la télévision et le
cinéma ont exposé le public à des
personnages dont ils ignoraient même
l'existence même s'il savait qui ils
étaient ils n'en comprenaient pas
nécessairement les sens je me souviens
quand j'ai vu le premier film de
Spider-Man celui de Sam Raimi à la mort
de l'oncle ben le public est déchiré
je connais cette histoire depuis l'âge
de 10 ans ça m'a bien sûr affecté quand
je l'ai lu mais je n'avais jamais pensé
à son effet sur un auditoire plus vaste
quand l'oncle ben meurt le public est
tout simplement dévasté
ça change tout
quand on reste fidèle à l'esprit d'une
bande dessinée que moi et des millions
d'autres personnes adorants quand on la
transpose bien à l'écran on peut faire
beaucoup d'argent
consciente des énormes revenus
potentiels de ces superproductions la
machine hollywoodienne s'emballe de Rock
Sort à l'été 2003 de Fantastic Four et
sont déjà en préparation 6 ans seulement
après que Marvel ait frôlé la faillite
les créations de Stan Lee sont
maintenant les propriétés
intellectuelles de plus grandes valeurs
dans le domaine du divertissement ce qui
s'est passé c'est que les cinéastes sont
soudainement rendu compte qu'il existe
marché pour des films plus grands nature
avec des héros colorés et de merveilleux
effets spéciaux et de toute évidence il
n'y a pas de meilleur endroit pour
trouver tout ça que dans les bandes
dessinées en particulier avec Marvel
a été la deuxième création de Stanley et
Jacoby pour Marvel Comics dans les
années 1960 à quel archétype
correspond-t-il à Frankenstein avec un
peu de Jake
c'est un scientifique maigrelet qui se
fait bombarder de rayons gamma et qui se
transforme en une brute monstrueuse il
n'a aucun désir de défendre des libertés
civiles les vertus civiques ou
l'Amérique il ne pense qu'à lui-même
l'incroyable hold qui a été le premier
grand succès télévisé de Marvel dans les
années 1970 et 80
c'était bien joué et son thème était
similaires à celui du fujitif l'émission
de télévision des années 1960 un thème
tragique qui à mon avis reflétait bien
la bande dessinée c'était un super héros
différent il ne voulait pas des pouvoirs
qu'il avait acquis l'émission était très
réussie pour la télévision à l'époque
même si les amateurs de la BD avaient
beaucoup de choses à lui reprocher mais
au grand écran on voulait bien sûr
quelque chose de mieux c’était désormais
possible d'avoir un rock plus grand
beaucoup plus fort et plus fidèle aux
bandes dessinées
[Musique]
ni derrière le film rock de 2003 le
réalisateur Taïwanais Angly est le
cinéaste le plus acclamé par la critique
et le plus reconnu à jamais avoir
entrepris l'adaptation d'une bande
dessinée de super-héros son film
s'intéresse plus à la psychologie à
l'action et son scénario est truffé
d'allusion en classique littéraire et à
la mythologie
j'ai adoré old en 2003 je voulais déjà
voir le film parce que j'avais regardé
l'émission de télé et que j'aimais holk
mais sinon j'y serai allé pour le
réalisateur
à ce moment là il était assez évident
que la mode des films de bande dessinée
à l'espursuivre c'était donc très
intéressant qu'il choisisse un
réalisateur comme Angeli et qui lui dise
voici un grand bonhomme vert qui porte
un pantalon violet fait ce que tu veux
avec lui
[Musique]
ça semblait logique un cinéaste comme
Burton fasse une adaptation de BD mais
ringly quoi ça a quand même donné un peu
plus de poids au film tiré de BD pour
ceux qui n'y voyaient peut-être rien
d'autre que des affaires d'enfants
[Musique]
il est visuellement très proche d'une
bande dessinée lisse sert des cases de
BD comme procédé de montage il emploie
des couleurs primaires vives et les
scènes d'action sont joyeusement
démesurées
mais ça a été un échec encore une fois
le public a rejeté ce qui était en fait
un film d'auteur déguisé en adaptation
de BD
comme pour Batman Returns la leçon que
Hollywood en a tiré c'est qu'on peut
bien engager de grands réalisateurs mais
il ne faut pas les laisser succomber
complètement à leur folie
l'ambition du film de Angeli et louable
si on le compare à la Balanche de
production décevante qui ont suivi après
le dernier vol mais quand on veut d'être
Ben Affleck la deuxième version filmée
du Punisher et un fantastique for mièvre
et familiale la série de succès de
Marvel prend fin alors que Catwoman avec
Halle Berry se retrouve bientôt dans la
liste des pires films de tous les temps
les suites parviennent cependant à
maintenir l'entreprise à flot notamment
Spiderman to de sa Rémi et exto de Brian
senior salué comme deux des meilleurs
films du
genrees surtout parmi les films de
super-héros les effets spéciaux étaient
encore plus avancés à ce moment-là même
s'il ne s'est écoulé que quelques années
entre les deux films les effets étaient
plus convaincants ils en ont repoussé
les limites
surtout avec le personnage du Docteur
Octopus et ses membres extensibles
certaines scènes se démarquent encore
c'est du cinéma de qualité supérieure
comme le combat dans le train et celui
sur le côté de l'édifice c'est vraiment
réussi et c'est très divertissant
sur le plan de la fidélité à la source
ex-t2 était probablement la référence à
l'époque pour ce qui est de donner vie à
une bande dessinée
ex to ressemble à un livre de poche
concentré
le premier acte de ce film reste à mes
yeux l'une des meilleures adaptations de
BD jamais réalisées
est un personnage fantastique les
premières séquences à la Maison Blanche
ou les effets spéciaux dominent sont
très amusants on n'avait jamais rien vu
de semblable
film qui a montré que tout était
possible les personnages utilisent tout
le temps leurs pouvoirs sans mamie
penser non seulement les effets spéciaux
sont-ils fantastiques mais ils sont
aussi parfaitement intégrés ils ne sont
pas forcés narrativement parlant c'est
pourquoi ils sont si impressionnants on
avait enfin réussi
les progrès technologiques ne facilitent
pas seulement le passage des super-héros
au grand écran ils aident également les
amateurs de bandes dessinées à se
rapprocher
auparavant le courrier des lecteurs et
les magasins de BD constituaient les
seuls forums ou les fans pouvaient
échanger mais l'avènement de l'ère
numérique permet désormais aux gens
autrefois isolés d'en rencontrer
d'autres sur Internet qui partagent leur
passion
l'Internet a beaucoup aidé à promouvoir
ainsi qu'à élargir la culture des femmes
que ce soit pour les BD ou pour toutes
sortes d'autres obsessions les amateurs
de bandes dessinées se sentaient souvent
un peu seuls à part quelques amis qui
s'intéressaient à ça
électroniques ont créé cette vaste
communauté internationale où chacun
pouvait faire des commentaires sur les
BD ou les super-héros les lecteurs
pouvaient désormais contribuer à
façonner les BD parce que les auteurs et
les dessinateurs on entend des parler
aussi
la culture des babillards électroniques
de la fin des années 1990 et du début
des années 2000 un raccourci la distance
entre les lecteurs et les créateurs les
dessinateurs et les auteurs sont devenus
plus accessibles on pouvait maintenant
dialoguer avec eux les amateurs ont
commencé à échanger sur ce qu'ils
aimaient ou non dans les films ou les BD
grâce à l'Internet et aux communautés en
ligne on a assisté à l'éclatement de la
culture des fans
c'est ensuite donné lieu à
l'organisation de tous ces congrès et
toutes ces conventions de femmes qu'il y
a actuellement la culture de la BD a
donné lieu à la culture des fans plus
généralement des gens qui se réunissent
et célèbres ce qu'ils aiment
les premières années du nouveau
millénaire sont marqués par l'arrivée de
nombreux personnages bien-aimés de
Marvel au grand écran
a fait quelque chose d'assez remarquable
mais très simple il a été le premier
grand cinéaste à raconter comme on le
disait en 1940 qui est Batman et doux il
est venu
c'est le premier film qui traite des
origines de Batman une histoire
déchirante c'est très émouvant très
efficace et très bien fait
cette décision à elle seule donne à
Chris learning les trois camps de son
film
notre travail à Denis et moi a
influencer ce premier film ça se voyait
à l'écran
quand on regarde les adaptations de DC
qui ont été tournées le premier de cette
trilogie-là est vraiment à tomber par
terre
on ne peut pas sous-estimer à quel point
Batman Begins est une réussite d'abord
Christopher brillant voyez comment
l'histoire se déroule comment il la
raconte
il utilise des effets spéciaux pratiques
afin d'éviter autant que possible les
images de synthèse mais pour des raisons
esthétiques et non financières
ça a donné une version urbaine de Batman
que le monde entier était prêt à
accueillir
sauf peut-être Joël
comme pour Superman et X-Men on assemble
une multitude d'acteurs de renom pour
incarner les rôles principaux de Batman
Begins
c'est l'acteur britannique acclamé mais
encore peu connu Kristen Berne qui
interprète Bruce Wayne Liam Neeson
Michael Keane et plusieurs autres
acteurs estimés complètent cette
distribution des plus impressionnantes
cela confère un poids dramatique
considérable au film établissant
immédiatement un nouveau standard en
matière de cinéma de super-héros
à sa sortie je savais qui était
Christine Dale et j'étais impatient de
voir ce qu'il ferait du personnage mais
je n'en avais aucune idée je connaissais
des trucs de Nolan mais je ne
m'imaginais pas ce que ça allait donner
belle était vraiment bon l'histoire
était lugubre et ancrée dans la réalité
c'était tout nouveau pour les films
tirés de BD
n'était pas un grand amateur de BD ce
n'était pas un fan qui avait enfin
l'occasion de faire ce qu'il voulait
c'était plutôt un cinéaste dramatique
sérieux qui a pris ce sujet dans les
tensions d'en faire quelque chose de
vrai
dans ses Batman Nolan a été le premier à
aborder la mythologie des super-héros
comme un récit dramatique légitime
je reconnais à Warner Brothers et à
Nollen le mérite de cette engagé autant
qu'il l'ont fait dans cette voie
réaliste parce qu'il y a toute une
génération pour qui c'est la version
première de Batman ça le définit pour
eux
grâce à Batman les films de super-héros
et les bandes dessinées elles-mêmes
jouissent désormais d'un plus grand
respect l'année de sa sortie en 2005 on
voit également des adaptations de bandes
dessinées en compétition pour la
première fois à Cannes le plus
prestigieux festival international de
cinéma Sin City réalisé par Robert
Rodriguez
canadien David cranenberg s'inscrivent
dans la lignée des films Road
toperdition et gosworld et démontre que
la bande dessinée est un art à prendre
au sérieux
les films qui n'étaient pas basés sur
des BD de super-héros ont montré à
beaucoup de monde qui ne lit pas de
bandes dessinées qu'elles ont beaucoup
plus à offrir que des gains spandex ces
gens prennent donc le média plus au
sérieux maintenant ce ne sont pas
seulement des histoires à quatre sous on
peut raconter une très belle histoire
avec ce média en lui ajoutant une autre
dimension grâce à l'aspect visuel
le public commence à reconnaître à quel
point les bandes dessinées de grande
qualité peuvent être captivantes
que les gens ne sachent pas que ce film
est inspiré d'une bande dessinée parce
que j'adore le leur dire j'ajoute c'est
une adaptation très fidèle il s'en
gratte la tête se doute quant à l'idée
qu'ils se font de la bande dessinée et
ce qui a mené à toutes les grandes
choses qui se sont produites depuis
pourtant dans les années qui suivent la
sortie de Batman Begins le genre semble
encore fragile les adaptations de
Marveaux continuent d'échouer
Electra Ghost Rider et la suite de
Fantastic Four reçoivent un accueil peu
enthousiaste tandis que les 3e films des
populaires séries X-Men et Spider-Man
déçoivent les fans en coulisses Marvel
cherche maintenant à reprendre son
destin en main
dans les années 1990 Marvel conseillait
ses personnages sous licence à
différents studios
les droits sur Iron Man Thor Captain
America et peut-être aussi Black Panther
à l'époque Fox avait l'univers des X-Men
comme on le sait Sony avait Spider-Man
et Universal avait Hulk au milieu des
années 2000 sous la direction de Noma
pli David maeso Marvel a décidé
d'adopter un autre modèle d'affaires
pour le cinéma
suggère que Marvel développe et produit
ses propres films en devenant une
société de production à part entière
Marvel conserverait le contrôle
artistique et financier des œuvres qui
lui appartiennent c'est une décision
risquée car elle exige un financement
externe substantiel et l'entreprise ne
détient pas non plus les droits
cinématographiques sur certains de ces
personnages les plus connus sous la
direction de David mysel et du
producteur Kevin Faguy Marvel annonce
rapidement ses projets à la presse et le
tournage de son premier film débute en
j'avais publié un article à la une de la
section à faire du elle est Times il y
avait une image de rock de Tours et
Darwin man c'était avant le premier film
d'Iron Man le titre était l'équipe B ce
n'était pas X-Men la bande dessinée la
plus vendue aux États-Unis ce n'était
pas Spider-Man c'était des personnages
moins connus mais il n'y a rien de mal à
être inconnu
tant qu'on fait une bonne première
impression
c'est Iron Man et l'homme derrière son
armure de métal Tony Stark qu'on choisit
pour faire cette première impression et
lancer Marvel studio en 2008
comme Blade disons auparavant il s'agit
encore une fois d'un personnage moins
connu du grand public
les lecteurs assidus de bandes dessinées
eux suivent ses aventures depuis sa
création par Stan Lee en 1963
a débuté avec ses personnages de
deuxième rang les lecteurs savaient de
qui il s'agissait mais pas le grand
public avant la sortie du film Iron Man
il y a eu une grande campagne
publicitaire pour informer les gens que
ce n'était pas un robot les fans de BD
le savaient déjà Iron Man est un
personnage intéressant et son choix est
très opportun il est apparu au moment où
les États-Unis se préparaient à entrer
en guerre au Vietnam
Tony Stark est issu du complexe
militaron industriel il travaille comme
entrepreneur de la défense pour le
gouvernement blessé au Vietnam il se
fabrique cette combinaison Diamond parce
que c'est un génie de la technologie
c'est facile à adapter aux années 2000
quand les États-Unis mènent des guerres
semblables en Afghanistan et en Irak
encore une fois il y a une tension chez
un personnage qui essaie de dominer la
technologie mais qui se sont aussi
distants de tout ça il fait toujours
partie de ce complexe militar ou
industriel mais il indique clairement
qu'il va porter son attention ailleurs
et aider les gens
dans une culture obsédée par la
technologie il n'y a pas de meilleur
super-héros que Iron Man pour jouer avec
ses tensions cette relation amour haine
ou amour crainte qu'on a tous avec la
technologie
était une gageure parce que les gens ne
savaient pas qui c'était mais moi
j'étais vraiment excité
avec un personnage comme Batman ou
Captain America on a l'impression qu'ils
vont rater leurs coups ils vont me
gâcher mon Capitaine America ou mon
Batman
est un peu connu on pouvait en faire à
peu près tout ce qu'on voulait c'était
brillant comme décision
quand on veut lancer un univers
cinématographique tout à fait unique il
faut commencer par quelqu'un que
personne ne connaît
le choix de l'acteur que personne ne
connaît n'est toutefois pas envisageable
le succès du film dépend du visage
familier qui interprétera Tony Stark à
l'insistance du réalisateur John Favreau
un acteur apparu dans les années 80 sa
carrière a déraillé à cause de la
consommation de drogue et des périodes
d'emprisonnement mais elle connaît une
renaissance à l'époque d'Harry man il se
révèle parfait dans le rôle c'est le
rôle de sa vie beaucoup de gens
pensaient que c'était celui de Charlie
Chaplin mais ce type là est né pour
incarner ton histoire
grandit sous le regard du public tout ce
qui s'est passé de bien et de mal dans
sa vie tout le monde l'a vu ton histoire
que lui aussi grandit en public c'est un
génie tout le monde apprécie son talent
était un choix logique il a des
antécédents de toxicomanie tout comme
Iron Man donnez avait traversé bien des
épreuves c'était encore un acteur
respecté mais sa carrière n’était pas
aussi florissante qu'aujourd'hui je
dirais donc ce qu'il a fait pour Iron
Man Iron Man la fait aussi pour lui
Tony Stark est un personnage merveilleux
on peut le comparer à Batman d'une
certaine façon en ce sens que c'est un
multimillionnaire et un génie mais son
attrait est différent le côté sombre de
Batman et fantastique et ça marche pour
lui ce qui a marché pour Iron Man c'est
qu'il était vraiment drôle
avec Robert dont les problèmes sont
tristement célèbres et qui n’est plus
jeune personne allait penser que c'était
un film pour enfant
ça s'attaque à de grandes questions il y
a des scènes qui se déroulent en
Afghanistan il y a Jeff Bridges et se
passe beaucoup de choses dans ce film
Iron Man a été présenté avec succès
comme un film de super-héros destiné à
des gens qui pourraient être gênés
d'aller voir un film de super-héros il y
avait des vedettes adultes de cinéma
Robert Downey
Patrol Jeff Bridges c'était presque un
film prestigieux de bande dessinée au
niveau de Batman Begins mais il sort
début mais étonne tout le monde en
faisant 102 millions de dollars à son
week-end de d'ouverture c'est le
deuxième plus gros résultat pour un film
qui n'est pas une suite après Spider Man
ce lundi-là Marvel est arrivé en disant
voici ce qu'on va faire maintenant
Marvel révèle une ambitieuse liste de
productions à venir des films en solo
pour chacun de ces personnages clés
suivi d'un film collectif dit Avengers
plus tard la même année Diane sort en
salle mais il reçoit un accueil beaucoup
plus tiède carineman malgré cet accroc
les producteurs de Marvel restent
convaincus de pouvoir adapter mieux que
quiconque leur super-héros au grand
écran peu après ce premier d'une longue
série de succès pour Marvel la tête
d'affiche de DC revient dans les cinémas
ces Batman Begins avaient établi une
nouvelle référence en matière
d'adaptation de bande dessinée de Dark
Knight s'avère encore plus glauque
Christopher continue de repousser les
limites du cinéma fantastique en
ramenant l'ennemi juré de Batman le
Joker au grand écran
l'acteur australien Hitler qui décède
quelques mois avant la sortie du film
incarne ce personnage comme nul autre
avant lui le côté sombre était assez
surprenant dans The Dark Knight ça
explore des thèmes où on s'attendrait à
ce qu'un film policier a suspense aille
plus loin qu'un film de BD mais Batman
l'avait laissé présager avec son
approche beaucoup plus réaliste du
personnage son gars peut me ressemblait
beaucoup plus à une ville réelle
affligée par le crime qu'elle métropole
de bande dessinée le public était
vraiment emballé de voir une histoire
opposant le Batman ou Joker se déroulait
dans ce monde-là avec le choix inspiré
de hit Ledger dont le Joker avait l'air
plutôt sinistre
n'oubliez pas que la bande-annonce du
film est sorti avant sa mort on avait
donc déjà une bonne idée du genre de
Joker qui l'incarnerait
ça suscité beaucoup d'intérêt parce
qu'il s'agissait du dernier rôle complet
de hit Ledger
[Applaudissements]
on ne voit pas beaucoup d'interprétation
si intense que celle-là surtout dans des
rôles de méchants de films de
super-héros il a creusé si profondément
dans ce personnage que son était
vraiment terrifiant c'est une des
premières choses dont les gens se
souviennent et qu'ils adorent dans The
Dark Knights la performance de
hitlero ça aurait été de Dark Knight
c'était la première fois que quelqu'un
s'engageait à fournir les ressources
nécessaires pour sortir les bandes
dessinées du domaine de la culture
populaire ce n'était pas seulement un
excellent film tiré d'une BD c'était un
excellent film tout court qui traitait
d'un personnage de bandes dessinées il y
a une grande différence les acteurs sont
incroyables le talent de en Nolwenn
s'est entouré pour faire ce film et
stupéfiant avec un réalisateur comme
Nolan qui produit des œuvres incroyables
sur le plan cinématographique ça n'a
rien d'étonnant qu'il s'agisse des
premiers films de super-héros à être
sérieusement prise en considération pour
des prix
pour son interprétation après sa mort
ça provoque un certain tolé quand aucun
de ces films là ne s'est retrouvé en
lice pour le prix du meilleur film
pourquoi donc ne prend pas ses films ou
au sérieux non seulement au sein de leur
catégorie mais en tant que œuvre de
cinéma
après le succès d'Iron Man et de Dark
Knight les adaptations de bandes
dessinées se multiplient et envahissent
la culture populaire les studios cours
désespérément à la recherche de nouveaux
personnages et de titres à présenter au
grand écran Iron Man revient pour une
suite réussie et Hugh Jackman
chancelante pour se consacrer aux
aventures en solo de Wolverine après
avoir signé un lucratif accord de vente
avec Disney en 2011 Marvel lance les
deux chapitres suivants de sa saga
cinématographique Thor est le premier
d'entre eux a sorti comme pour Iron Man
avant lui ce film marquent les débuts du
personnage au grand écran
Thor est le dieu du tonnerre il possède
une arme de destruction massive
extrêmement puissante que lui seul peut
utiliser parce que personne d'autre
n'est digne de soulever ce fardeau
a su puiser dans une autre mythologie
qu'on étudie pas vraiment dans la
culture occidentale
on a nos Grecs et nos romans mais les
dieux nordiques sont eux aussi très cool
un Dieu qui produit du tonnerre avec un
marteau et qui lance des éclairs on
n'avait jamais vu ça avant
malgré la longue histoire du personnage
dans le monde des bandes dessinées Thor
n'est pas très connu du grand public lui
non plus c'est un risque que Marvel
studio et son cerveau le président à la
production Kevin figuy sont heureux
d'affronter sûr qu'ils en feront un
succès avec l'acteur et cinéaste
britannique chevronné canette Brana à la
barre du projet on se permet même choix
audacieux c'est l'acteur australien
inconnu Chris Hemsworth qui incarnera ce
héros tout aussi peu familier
c'est un mélange de mythologie nordique
avec de la prose shakespearienne dans le
monde fantastique des mains d'un jack
Kirby sous l'effet du LSD
quand ils ont annoncé le film je me
demandais comment diable vont-ils faire
tout le reste de l'univers est tellement
ancré dans la réalité je ne voyais pas
comment tort pourraient s'y intégrer
quand je me suis assis pour la première
fois avec les gens de Marvel ils m'ont
dit c'est notre propriété la plus
délicate il y a tellement de façons dans
sa pourra échouer j'ai pensé ça commence
bien j'ai regardé ça pour voir quel
était c'est indiqué action
science-fiction fantastique aventure
drame ça fait beaucoup de catégories je
crois que tous ces éléments se
retrouvent dans la BD le plus grand défi
devient alors le ton à adopter
[Applaudissements]
Thor sur le papier c'est assez difficile
à ventre
ça étire manifestement les limites de la
crédibilité
après avoir présenté Iron Man comme un
habitant du monde réel qui affronte des
problèmes réels dans un monde très réel
et très sérieux on nous sort un lieu
scandinaves ça peut avoir de la
difficulté à passer là où ça fonctionne
à merveille c'est que c'est vraiment
drôle
essentiellement il s'agit d'une comédie
fantastique du genre poisson hors de
l'eau qui ne se prend pas du tout au
sérieux
était le choix parfait
aurait pu mal tourner je trouve qu'ils
ont fait du bon travail emsworth aussi
ce type n'est pas acteur à la blague il
est grand bâti beau et tout le reste
mais il est vraiment très bon parce que
c'est un rôle ingrat il aurait pu avoir
l'air si ridicule et si stupide
bien qu'il obtienne moins de succès
karenman Thor attire tout de même des
foules considérables l'anticipation est
maintenant à son comble pour l'autre
titre de Marvel en 2011 Captain America
the First Avenger ce personnage est le
plus ancien du répertoire de la
compagnie il s'agit d'un symbole de
propagande datant de l'entrée des
États-Unis dans la seconde guerre
mondiale au début des années 40
fidèle aux origines du personnage
l'action de Captain America de First
Avenger se déroule principalement
pendant la Seconde Guerre mondiale
un autre acteur peu connu qui interprète
le super héros sous la direction du
réalisateur de film d'aventure Joe
Johnston
bien que le personnage principal soit
mieux connu du public que Thor et Iron
Man le film n'a pas le succès escompté
il divise le pignon dès son lancement
pour la quand j'ai entendu dire qu'ils
allaient faire un film de Captain
America j'étais inquiète parce que ça a
parfois été assez cucul dans le passé il
a été créé comme moyen de propagande
avec sa tenue bleue blanche et rouge
c'est difficile à réussir le premier
film a joué là-dessus c'était très clair
qu'il était lui-même la création d'un
autre tout comme son costume ce n'était
pas son idée de le porter s'il n'avait
pas fait ça le film aurait échoué en
grande partie
d'une certaine façon Captain America est
le Superman de l'univers Marvel en ce
sens que c'est un héros patriotique
américain jusqu'à la moelle mais son
histoire n'est sans doute pas aussi
intéressante
elle ne l'est certainement pas dans le
premier film qui est de la vie de
beaucoup un des plus faibles de
l'univers Marvel bien que le succès au
box-office de Thor et de Captain America
ne soit pas à la hauteur de celui d'Iron
Man tout semble indiquer que le plan
audacieux de Marvel Studios se déroule
sans heurt il ne s'agit pas non plus
d'un simple engouement pour les films de
super-héros une autre production à
grands budget de l'été Green Lantern de
DC Comics savaient un échec critique et
commercial notable
Marvel semble toutefois suivre ses
propres règles sa stratégie de film
multiple qu'on appellera bientôt
l'univers cinématographique Marvel
traite chaque film comme un volet de
l'ensemble plus vaste où tout est relié
avec des acteurs engagés pour incarner
le même personnage à plusieurs reprises
si Marvel réussi cet univers inter relié
constituera un accomplissement
révolutionnaire il y a d'ailleurs pas
seulement sa stratégie qui est unique
l'approche des producteurs envers le
cinéma de super-héros est également
inhabituel auparavant l'élan créatifs
qui donnaient souffle aux adaptations
venaient souvent de réalisateurs au
style distant de Tim Burton à Angly en
passant par Brian Singer et Christopher
Nollen qui offrait leur propre
interprétation du matériel source la
vision de Marvel est entre les mains de
son président à la production Kevin
figuier peu importe le réalisateur
chaque film doit s'insérer dans un cadre
beaucoup plus vaste
le plus grand test de cette ambitieux
projet arrive au printemps 2012
après nous avoir fait connaître ses
principaux super-héros dans une série de
films individuels Marvel les réunit tous
dans The Avengers
cette méga production bat des records
d'entrée dans le monde entier dès son
lancement et devient bientôt le film de
super-héros le plus lucratif de tous les
temps
ils ont bâti leur univers film par film
en s'appuyant sur chaque nouveau succès
le fait d'avoir un plan de jeu qui
consiste à mettre en place toutes ces
séries disparates puis à faire en sorte
que les personnages se rencontrent tous
dans une grande production c'était
inédit c'était génial
ça offre au public un niveau de
continuité inégalée qu'il ne peut pas
trouver ailleurs
[Musique]
ce qu'ils ont fait avec l'univers
intervulier c'est ahurissant je n'arrive
toujours pas à croire qu'ils aient
réussi à mettre les Avengers sur film ça
fait déjà plusieurs années mais ça
m'étonne encore qu'ils aient soit
parvenu
[Musique]
le premier film des Avengers était
absolument génial
je ne crois pas avoir jamais vraiment
ressenti une telle agitation dans une
salle de cinéma auparavant on n'était
pas sûr que ce serait bon pour les fans
de bandes dessinées c'était une joie
absolue de voir ces personnages enfin
partager l'écran et le film était plus
que la somme de ses parties ils étaient
donc meilleurs ensemble que séparément
tandis que l'univers de Marvel se révèle
enfin dans toute sa gloire une série
concurrente s'apprête à dévoiler son
dernier épisode de tort Knight Rises
sort quelques mois plus tard alors que
le public est encore vibrant lit par
l'impact de The Avengers russe le
costume de la chauve-souris pour la
dernière fois et affronte son
compatriote britannique Tomb Raider dans
le rôle de pain ce méchant moins connu
créé par Chuck Jackson et granolong a
quand même déjà fait une brève
apparition d'un Batman en 1997
que dans Batman and Robin ce n'est pas
un homme de mains stupide ils l'ont
présenté comme un cerveau et comme un
dur à cuire ce qui est plus important
intelligent et dur à cuire
[Musique]
ils en ont fait un personnage familier
tout le monde sait de qu'il s'agit
maintenant je me fais encore à l'idée
on a eu une idée folle et on les voit
sur des jouets des porte-clés des
pyjamas des costumes d'Halloween partout
l'interprétation époustouflante du Joker
par Hitler est encore fraîche dans la
mémoire des cinéphiles quand le film
sort en juillet 2012 ce dernier chapitre
de la trilogie de Christopher Nollen a
donc beaucoup pas faire pour combler les
attentes la présence du Joker dans The
Dark Knight avait eu tellement d'impact
qu'il allait inévitablement manquer au
public dans le film suivant tout le
monde voulait leur voir si les choses
s'étaient pas assez différemment pour
Hitler qui sait quelle direction le
troisième film aurait employé
ce que j'aime beaucoup c'est que c'est
une des rares séries de super-héros qui
a une fin
on ne reverra peut-être jamais ça
d'ailleurs
ça a une fin claire et complète qui
suggère que les cinéastes y avait pensé
débattements et cette fin est assez
touchante à mon avis
[Musique]
il a fait ce qu'il voulait il a réussi
c'est l'histoire qu'il voulait raconter
c'est cohérent et c'est superbe
visuellement en soi je ne trouve pas ce
film là aussi fort que les deux
précédents mais la trilogie résistera
certainement à l'épreuve du temps
ces deux colosses cinématographiques
encaissent plus d'un milliard de dollars
chacun les super-héros contrôlent
maintenant le monde on assiste à une
véritable explosion de la culture des
bandes dessinées les produits dérivés de
toutes sortes affluent dans les magasins
la participation au congrès du milieu
augmente en flèche et personne n'a plus
à cacher sa passion comme un plaisir
coupable les séries X-Men et Spider-Man
quant à elle sont relancés sous une
nouvelle mouture après un troisième
chapitre décevant
la production de nouveaux films accélère
à Marvel Studios aroman 3 Thor et
Captain America winter shorter faut tous
l'objet de critiquer élogieuse et les
recettes au box-office ne cessent
d'augmenter
la tête dirigeante de l'entreprise qui
avait une fagui se retrouve très vite
sous les feux de la rampe la presse en
sens l'homme derrière le succès de plus
en plus convaincant de l'univers Marvel
c'est le style Jobs du cinéma l'histoire
va acheter un regard bienveillant sur
cet homme car on aura une vue d'ensemble
de son travail parce qu'on est encore en
plein milieu de tout ça
j'ignore c'est le public arrive vraiment
à apprécier l'ampleur de ce qu'il a
construit
c'est stupéfiant
cette domination de
la clinique incite
à faire revivre le premier grand
super-héros du cinéma en 2013 avec un
scénario de l'équipe de Batman Begins
Christopher
le réalisateur Zack Snyder derrière la
caméra et le jeune acteur britannique
Henry Caval dans le rôle principal Man
of Steel cherche à moderniser Superman
malgré les réactions négatives la
popularité du film convain Warner
Brothers de lui donner une suite le
succès de l'univers cinématographique
Marvel a cependant provoqué des ondes de
choc dans l'industrie et les séries
classiques ne semblent plus aussi
attrayantes
le souvenir du Batman de Kristen Bell ne
s'est pas encore estompé dans les
mémoires mais Warner Brothers cherche
tout de même à intégrer ce personnage
dans le monde de l'Homme d'Acier on
annonce bientôt le projet Batman contre
Superman le deuxième d'une série de
films qui doit comprendre des sorties
sur grand écran pour Wonder Woman
Aquaman et d'autres membres de la Ligue
de Justice de DC Comics cherchant son
propre Kevin figuier pour assurer la
cohérence de ce nouvel univers était
relié les producteurs en conflit la
direction créative au réalisateur Zack
Snyder avec Ben Affleck dans le rôle du
chevalier noir et gagdote interprétant
la première Wonder Woman au cinéma
Batman contre Superman down justice et
terrainé par le public et la critique
dès sa sortie
quand on regarde les films de DC il y a
certainement beaucoup de axes Snyder
là-dedans c'est lui qui a réalisé
Watchmen la première œuvre vraiment ni
liste sur les super-héros des
super-héros qui affrontent une situation
impossible à gagner
Man of Steel et Batman contre Superman
dans of Justice ont emprunté une boisson
on ne croit plus au héros
je voulais voir Batman et Superman se
battre depuis mon enfance c'était trop
cool
j'aurais dû être folle de ce film mais
j'ai l'impression que tout y était
forcés on est allé trop loin dans le
réalisme il n'y avait aucun sens de
l'amusement dans ce film Superman est
déprimé Batman est en colère il se
battent
Wonder Woman arrive et elle est géniale
mais il se remet en colère et recommence
à déprimer tout est sombre c'est mort
en partie parce qu'il trahi profondément
Batman et Superman qu'il transforme tous
deux en idiot irascible
ils sont violents égoïste et stupide
sagache aussi complètement le personnage
de Loïs Lane en faisant d'elle une
demoiselle en détresse dont il faut
s'occuper pendant tout le film c'était
une trahison totale de ces personnages
qu'on aime depuis si longtemps et une
énorme méprise
la tentative de Dissy visant à lancer un
univers capable de rivaliser avec celui
de Marvel se révèle extrêmement
décevante pourtant le cinéma de
super-héros en général ne cesse
d'établir des records et de gagner en
importance au sein de l'industrie
cinématographique le réalisateur Bryan
senior reprend les commandes de la série
X-Men qu'il renouvelle complètement en
combinant les acteurs originaux à une
nouvelle distribution plus jeune days of
future past le film qui en résulte
devient rapidement le plus lucratif de
la série du côté de Marvel Studios les
succès s'enchaînent toujours outre la
deuxième partie des Avengers de nouveaux
films font découvrir un public mondial
des personnages encore moins connus du
long passé de l'éditeur
était capable de faire un milliard de
dollars avec des personnages que même
les morts du de bande dessinée ne
connaissent pas
quand on parlait de super-héros qui ne
passerait jamais à l'écran Ant-Man quel
est le seul film qui ne marchera jamais
Ant-Man et c'était génial
pour dire on a réussi on a même eu du
succès avec un film sur Internet pendant
si longtemps c'était une blague
vont-ils un jour sortir un film Batman
la BD va-t-elle revenir le fait qu'ils
aient accompli cet exploit avec beaucoup
de succès encore une fois grâce à un
excellent choix d'acteur ça nous dit que
Marvel sentirait avec n'importe quoi
mais continue d'élargir son univers avec
de nouveaux personnages le Docteur
Strange fait ses débuts au cinéma et
Spider-Man vient enfin prendre sa place
dans l'univers Marvel la saga des X-Men
continue de se développer avec des fils
novateurs destinés à un public adulte
Deadpool Mel violence extrême et comédie
acerbe remportant un vif succès mondial
de son côté Logan nous offre le chant du
signe de Wolverine le sombre chapitre
final de l'histoire du personnage qui a
fait de Hugh Jackman une vedette
internationale bien qu'elle domine déjà
la culture populaire depuis plus d'une
décennie les adaptations de bandes
dessinées offrent encore de nouvelles
possibilités aux producteurs et aux
spectateurs d'ici et Marvel lance ainsi
en l'espace de 12 mois deux films qui
défilent les normes
devient la première femme à réaliser une
adaptation de super-héros pour un grand
studio américain avec Wonder Woman qui
donne finalement un film bien à lui à ce
personnage de 75 ans Marvel présente
ensuite Black Panther le super-héros
africain de Stanley et Jackie dans un
film en solo qui passera l'histoire
avant les dirigeants des studios
disaient les films avec des femmes ça ne
vont pas bien les films réalisés ou
interprétés majoritairement par des
personnes de couleur ça n'attire pas les
foules
il se trompait
pas besoin d'être une fille pour aimer
Wonder Woman tout le monde l'adore ça
leur a pris énormément de temps à
l'adapter au grand écran parce que les
studios avaient peur des films sur les
super héroïnes en voyant des films comme
Catwoman et Electra plusieurs se disent
les femmes ne peuvent pas être des
super-héros ce n'est pas ça il leur faut
de bons films c'est tout kangal Gadot a
été choisi les gens étaient un peu
inquiets elle n'en a pas l'air on s'en
fout elle était géniale
c'est un film extrêmement important et
extrêmement significatif
c'est ridicule très honnêtement étant
donné que ces univers existent en
parlant seulement de Marvel et DC depuis
10 ans 10 ans et pas un seul rôle
principal féminin
il y a plein de personnages secondaires
Black Widow qui est génial elle est
interprétée par scarlett Johansson une
des actrices les plus célèbres et les
plus rentables au monde on lui donne pas
son propre film c'est complètement fou
Wonder Woman est réalisé par une femme
qui s'est entourée de solide groupe
d'actrices pour la soutenir c'est très
significatif
en consacrant un premier film à une
super héroïne
évidemment Marvel a ensuite lancé Black
Panther qui représente un moment
culturel extrêmement important
c'est un film réalisé par des gens de
couleurs qui se déroulent en Afrique et
qui aborde de front des questions de
race
il n'y a pas seulement l'acteur
principal qui est noir la distribution
est majoritairement noire c'est vraiment
révolutionnaire on n'avait jamais vu ça
dans cet univers ni dans un autre
univers de super-héros ou dans tout
autre série de superproduction le projet
a été confié à Ryan Google un excellent
réalisateur qui a fait flood World
station et Creed tous deux avec Michael
big Jordan il semble avoir joui d'une
certaine liberté pour raconter
l'histoire qu'il voulait ça a donné
quelque chose de très important
de très politiques
de vraiment édifiant est original qui
reste malgré tout un film de Marvel
ils se sont servis de l'univers Marvel
pour soulever des questions qu'on ne se
poserait probablement pas dans les
multiplexes c'est incroyable
l'indéniable importance culturelle de
Black Panther et son immense succès
commercial démontre non seulement que
l'engouement pour les super-héros
perdure mais qu'il jouissent également
d'une énorme influence alors que le
public du monde entier découvre encore
des personnages qui existent pourtant
depuis un demi-siècle l'abondance de
héros et d'histoire qu'on a pas encore
transposé de la page à l'écran laisse
entrevoir un avenir prospère pour le
genre
cela dit bien que la popularité de ces
icônes soient actuellement à son apogée
la bande dessinée elle-même est
redevenue un domaine d'initié la place
des périodiques imprimées sur le marché
ayant fortement diminué à cause de
l'Internet depuis les années 90 tout
comme leur vente l'art qui a donné
naissance à ce phénomène mondial et
retourner dans l'ombre
[Musique]
pour ce qui est de la façon dont les
bandes dessinées sont perçues je ne
crois pas que ça ait changé où vous les
aimez ou vous ne les aimez pas il y a
beaucoup de monde qui n'aiment pas les
BD heureusement il y en a qui les aiment
vraiment beaucoup
[Musique]